faut peut-être reconnaître cette qualité
c'est qu'il met des mots sur un certain
nombre de problèmes du pays mais nous on
n'y met pas des mots nous on y met des
solutions enfin je veux dire là la
fonction du tribun sert de dénoncer la
fonction du constat c'est ce que faisait
le pen jean-marie le pen ya 30 ans dur
donc on n'est plus là dedans nous on
veut faire en sorte que notre projet on
puisse l'appliquer parce que je pense
vraiment que nos idées sont les bonnes
et ce n'est pas plus à la mode partagé
par une majorité de français mais on m'a
dit reste d'ailleurs puisqu'on est
donnée de puissants les poules soit quoi
c'est vrai je pense qu'on l'a encore ça
nous mais pour le coup on est donné au
second tour de l'élection partielle dans
tous les sens d'arrimer oui mais mon
coeur est là il faut une ambulance pour
vendre un peu de maquillage tout à coup
les voilà on est à vingt bien un sondage
qui est sorti à une heure on est affamé
et web et un sondage qui est sortie cela
n'a l'air à 16% elle a jamais été aussi
bas fouet avec une méthode qui est quand
même un peu particulière est contestable
dont même vos confrères avoue que c'est
uniquement les certitudes de vote donne
en contre mais franchement on est à sept
mois la grippe en flammes par des
morts-vivants ouais je suis confiant je
suis confiant pendant qu'on part je veux
dire mais marine le pen a fait beaucoup
de terrain il ya quelques jours elle
était à l'été à hayange elle et elle est
accueillie chaleureusement par les gens
qui ont un lien affectif killen qui
croient en l et es réclamaient notamment
à hayange et à quelques jours la
priorité nationale sert que nous c'est
un principe qu'on assume on veut que
dans le logement ou dans l'emploi par
rapport à quelqu'un qui vient de
l'étranger à compétences égales on donne
une priorité par la loi à quelqu'un qui
a la nationalité française est ce qu'on
appelle la priorité nationale beaucoup
de pays dans le monde font ça et ça
permet de donner une priorité aux
français chez eux parce que choisi
marine le pen bout cela et 26 ans est
beau gosse non mais je vous renvoie le
compliment merci ne
moi j'ai grandi c'est pourquoi j'ai
grandi à saint denis dans le 93 et j'ai
été confronté à ces jeunes comme tous
les jeunes qui grandit dans le 93
d'ailleurs à la violence
et vous bien ça rires et vous pensez
vous avez pensé que marine le pen était
la meilleure réponse pourrait et celle
d'abus ou pas j'ai vu en elle une femme
courageuse vous l'avez rencontré la
première fois que j'ai vu c'est un
meeting moi j'ai commencé au j'ai
commencé comme militants jeunes à partir
de 16 ans coller des affiches away dans
la cité des bosquets à montfermeil
d'accord nous y sommes ans à nu les
ennuis et g ouais mais voyez ça moi j'ai
jamais eu peur de m'engager jamais eu
peur de défendre mes idées sont déjà
biaisé un homme et vous par exemple
quand vous montez à la tribune du ccf
qui a été dissous pour proximité avec
l'islamisme pour revendiquer vos
idéologies faisait très bien dont acte
quand vous faites sur les par exemple
allah akbar à 100 mètres du bataclan en
novembre 2019 dans une manifestation
contre l'islamophobie mois
d'efforts si vous y étiez non mais c'est
pas possible je sais que je suis un
rosier est ici si vous y étiez avec des
propos d'un maton non mais attendez
attendez je redis je sais que c'est
toujours horrible camarades parlent
mieux français que vous je nie c'est pas
moi qui suis responsable je ne suis pas
responsable de tout ce qui se passe pour
les lire sur vos fiches j'aimais ma
région et même la déclaration que vous
avez tenus sur la sueur là bas sur la
scène
la scène quand vous êtes dans une
manifestation on hurle allah akbar à 100
mètres du bata qu'en novembre 2010 au
bar ou allah nous les musulmans nous ne
sommes pas dans un projet d'assimilation
la france doit s'habituer au fait que
nous restons si vous ne nous aimait pas
nous avons préparé nos enfants voyez à
quelques mètres d'un lieu où il y a eu
un attentat ya quinze jours alors jordan
donc là moment je vous est le faux nez
de l'islamisme en france
jordan très bien on peut en débattre je
préfère léger comme vous j'ai assumé et
jordan jardin on va remettre les choses
dans leur contexte je vous le redis
droit dans les yeux vous avez deux ans
devant vous des gens lever la main
autour de cette table des gens qui sont
100% français gaulois lever la main
d'accord je crois que vraiment je vous
dis la vérité mais quel rapport non mais
laissez moi aller au bout je vous ai
laissé je me suis réalisé sur la prairie
quand même dire la vérité nous ne sommes
pas dans un projet d'assimilation
puisque c'est pas parce que vous vous
l'êtes que par conséquent vous demander
à des gens d un permis d'être français
être français c'est respecter la loi
c'est bien dans son pays et j'ai envie
de vous dire moi je suis pas un soldat
de la simulation je suis un soldat
nalisation ont réussi que ça vous plaise
ou non et oui nos enfants il s'avère que
ils réussissent aussi à l'école et
qu'ils ont une réponse républicaine
et vous aujourd'hui je vous dis la
vérité pour je aller plus loin que cyril
moi je pense qu'il a été gentil avec
vous depuis tout à l'heure en fait les
gens veulent plus du front national
parce que vous rappeler la série dallas
il n' y est ce une tante arguant opère
un héritage et tous les cinq ans il ya
une saison qui arrive je vous dis la
vérité
et disait yann parce que c'est quand
même un homme de lettres je vous
conseille de lire le livre de quelqu'un
qui m'a donné envie d'être humoriste
c'est un italien s'appelle françois
cavanna il est mort dans les attentats
de charlie ça m'a beaucoup affecté il a
écrit un livre sur bing qui s'appelle
les rides n'est pas mort dans les
hauteurs d'alger
mais juste pour vous dire quelque chose
j'espère que vous plaisantez non mais je
vais aller avait émis une fatwa sur le
front de zineb el rhazoui mais tout cas
le journaliste qui attention et et
urbains sensibles dans la chasse au
titre après qu'elle ait suffisamment de
géo j'ai suffisamment d'argent vous avez
twitté vous suivre la d entretien l'an
2000 varlet par vous n'utilisez
définitive jordan sur un ministre de
l'éducation nationale vous sur des
journalistes mais c'est le charlie hebdo
à ses pattes ou étiez mal dans votre
peau que j'adresse fois que vous décidez
de dire que tous les arabes et les noirs
favori et
je veux le dit vraiment on vous reçoit
par pitié parce qu'objectivement ça n'a
pas commencé que déjà zemmour il est à 5
0 à la mi temps vous nous manquez le
front national il est où notre petit
front national qui disait on va on
déteste les [ __ ] on déteste les
[ __ ] on déteste les ou par vous êtes
tous zemmour il le fait mieux que vous
tous les jours et je suis d'accord avec
ce qu'ils étaient mal à l'aise là dessus
mais pourquoi je suis mal à l'aise et
vous êtes mal à l'aise parce que vous
êtes un comique qui ne fait rire
personne
non mais vous êtes
non je suis vraiment je suis né en
france vous incarnez pour moi une
idéologique que je combats et jordan et
vous est pour moi le faux nez de
l'islamisme et non jordan que vous
pouvez pas nommer la série là mais
j'aimerais bien par laser ne paniquent à
montretout avec jean marie louvel bas
vous pouvez pas vous réclamez yassine
belattar dieu la vie d'une victime d'un
attentat quand vous passez votre temps
non mais on ahmed et je m'assois ils les
gens et à les désigner comme bienvenue
pour les 600 soit arrosé avec la
journaliste de charlie hebdo mais
écoutez je vous en dis contre fo n'est
il déjà là tu ne seras plus leur 2020
c'est ça met des fatwas mais avec tout
le monde a vécu dans le pays je crois
que les balles arrêtées un sans gêne
sans me semble qu'on avait eu un
avantage est là mais je voudrais quelque
chose aujourd'hui objectivement
n'utilisaient pas des mots qui vous
dépasse vous faites ça toute la journée
je vais vous dire ce qui s'est passé et
c'est technique c'est qu'en fait il ya
eu des attentats totalement sordide et
je vous conseille fortement de faire
attention à ce que vous dites me
concernant je vous la fais des faits
isolés c'est ça oui de quoi vous parlez
il ya des attentats tous les jours en
france je vous parle ce qu'il ya des
attentes fou de 260 français qui son
mari dont ckoi et vous avez évoqué je
crois en parlant de l'assassinât du père
hamel à saint-etienne l'auvent normandie
vous avez parlé de ça comme d'un fait
isolé dans une interview et pascal
bruckner et vous avez parlé en ces
termes également de l'assassinât d'ilan
halimi de sara lee mais n'en faites en
automne alors vous avez dit ces mots les
compagnies caractère on avait parlé de
l'amdh effet les papiers et je vois la
vosgienne cora pas du tout je vous dis
quelque chose je mais vous n'allez pas
pouvoir faire un procès moi qui viens
tous les jours travailler avec un juif
et mais qui lie ces mecs je sais pas
mais il travaille de temps en temps je
vais vous dire d'ailleurs je souhaite
une bonne fête à nos amis juifs il y en
avait une mais au front national vous
étiez obligés de constater quelque chose
jordan bardella revenir d'un mois droit
dans les yeux vous faites partie d'un
parti qui a été créée par des anciens ss
n'oubliez jamais ça et sur l'échelle de
40 ans blé de nous faire croire que les
plus antisémites c'est ce qui n'était
pas parti qui faisait pas partie de ce
parti moi je traîne pas avec des nazis
mois et nés avec des islamismes a donc
et moi l'association nom a été mêlé sion